-Doesn't it feel good?
-Yeah, this chair feels great.
-It does.
And we get to talk about --
-There's just
no chair like this.
-Oh, I'm so happy.
-And I get to talk about myself.
-Welcome home!
-Come on!
-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-We got to talk
about the projects
that you've worked so hard on.
-I'm so happy to do that.
Are you okay with that?
-Oh, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Then Let's do it.
-Let's do it.
Before --
-Okay, okay.
What are we gonna do?
-Before we get into it,
I just --
-Oh, this is important.
-I have to talk about --
you have a new person
in your life -- a new --
-Well, person.
-A person in your life.
-I have a Muppet in my life.
-You have a Muppet in your life.
And I want to know all about...
[ Audience "Awws!" ]
-Yes.
-He is very cute.
-He's so cute, and I'm sorry
to have kept him from you,
but his name is Six-Thirty,
and I thought maybe
I was breaking the strike
if I talked about him.
I did not pick his name.
He picked it.
I just don't have the heart
to tell him that
it's just totally absurd
and inappropriate.
-Six-Thirty is his name.
-Yes.
-How did he pick his name?
-Well, he's a rescue and he was
very shy when I first got him.
We were trying all kinds
of different names.
My friends were throwing out,
like, everything under the sun.
And my best friend,
who is the food consultant
on "Lessons in Chemistry,"
she saw him and was like,
"Oh, my gosh!
He's Six-Thirty."
And he looked up, and I was
like, "Well, that's strange.
No." And then we said it again,
and I still didn't believe it.
And he just only
responded to "Six-Thirty."
I tried everything.
I had four days
where I was calling him Dog.
I was calling him --
I don't know --
Jeremy, Jimmy, David.
-You tried Jimmy, yeah.
-I'd be opening the pantry
and be like, "Are you flour?
Are you salt?
Are you black pepper?"
I don't know.
-Six-Thirty, he turns around.
-Mm-hmm.
-That's his name. He chose it.
-He chose it, so please just
respect him when you see him.
His vet thinks it's ridiculous,
His vet is confused.
Yes, the receptionist would go,
"You're Six-Thirty's here."
And he's like, "It's 2:00.
I don't know what that means."
-It's very confusing.
-Yeah, it's confusing.
-Can we talk about
"Lessons in Chemistry"?
-I'd love to.
-By the way, this is great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.
-Congratulations on this.
You're you're phenomenal in it,
but you also produced it.
How did you get involved
with this?
-It was brought to me and it
was actually brought to me
about two years
before the book even came out.
-It's a great book.
-Yeah, it's a fabulous book.
And it took about that long
to get it off the ground.
But, yeah, they asked me
to be a producer,
which has just been amazing,
because it helps me
with somebody --
Like, when I'm playing
someone like Elizabeth,
who's just such
a rich character,
it's nice to help
build her world
and be there
from the beginning.
And to be totally honest,
I've done this --
I've been acting
since I was like 7
and I've never really known
what a producer does.
I'm like, "Yeah, whatever."
Actually, they do a lot.
-Really, yeah. You learned?
-Let me tell you.
-You learned.
-Yeah, I learned that it's hard.
But it was just incredible.
We had the most incredible
cast and crew,
and I'm just happy
to finally say like,
"Hi, and I love you to everybody
who did 'Lessons in Chemistry.'"
-Yeah.
-You did such a great job.
I'm so proud of what we did.
-It's phenomenal. Please watch.
-Hi, Bonnie! Hi, Lee!
-Yes, hi, everyone.
Please watch.
It's actually --
It's phenomenal.
It's well-done,
well-shot, everything.
The sets, the costume,
the wardrobe, the acting.
Obviously, it's all good.
And I love the book, as well.
So congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-And then we can talk about
your giant movie, "The Marvels."
"The Marvels"
is in theaters today.
-Yeah, right now.
-This weekend, go see
"The Marvels."
You're back.
-Yes, please do.
I'd appreciate if you did.
-You back as Captain Marvel.
-I'm back, yeah, and I brought
some friends this time.
-Yeah, you did.
You know, gosh,
you've been on our show
even before you were cast
as Captain Marvel,
because I remember talking,
but I
remember how exciting it was,
like, "Oh, my gosh,
you're Captain Marvel.
This is massive."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then we just had Iman on
the show, who plays Ms. Marvel.
-Oh, my heart.
-She's so cool
and just the coolest kid.
I mean, she really is a kid.
And she said that you were
the first person
from the Marvel Universe to
call her and congratulate her.
-Yeah, I was, I was.
Yeah, I just think being
a superhero is, like,
a weird, specific job.
It's just like,
who else is going to be like,
"And make sure you have
extra zippers
so you can go
to the bathroom"?
You know, it's just, like,
very strange things.
And I felt really lucky,
because the first time
I played Captain Marvel
was on "Avengers,"
and so I had Scarlett Johansson
was the first person
who welcomed me,
and I got to be there
with all of them.
-She called you first?
-Yeah, yeah.
And, so, to have them
not just welcome me in,
but to also just be like,
"You've got this,"
and answer all my questions,
it was just so invaluable.
So I just make a point
whenever somebody --
When I read
that someone's a superhero,
I just go like, "If you want
info, like, I'm here.
I'm not, like,
actually Carol Danvers,
who's always like, super-busy.
Like, I'm fine.
Like, you can talk to me."
-"You can talk to me
about everything."
-Yeah, yeah.
I'm not always like, "Oh, no,
I'm on a control panel.
I can't talk."
Like, that's her.
-Okay, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have a pretty boring life,
actually, yeah.
-No. I know that you've become
close with one of your co-stars,
Samuel L. Jackson.
-My bestie.
-Really?
-Yeah, we're best friends.
Yeah, soul mates, really.
-Yeah.
-I know.
It's surprising
to everybody, including us.
-No, but you were
telling me backstage
that you guys text each other
and stuff like that.
-Oh, well, yes, of course.
I mean, he's really
big on emojis.
I can say that.
And he's also the person
that will send me, like,
videos of people falling
or, like, videos of, like,
corgis in inner tubes
going down the river, you know?
And if I don't respond
quick enough,
he's like, "Are you okay?"
-He's like, "Did you see
my funny video?
Yeah. Hello?"
-"Like, the Dr Pepper,
like, went crazy.
Are you not enjoying that?"
So, yes, he's -- We've done,
I think, five movies together,
and we're planning
our next five.
It's just --
Yeah, he's just my favorite.
-Good. I'm so happy.
-Yeah.
I'm his second favorite, so --
-Oh, is that right?
-Yeah, yeah.
On "The Marvels," actually,
there was a moment
we were working together,
and they're like,
"Could you do one more take?"
He's like, "Of course,
of course.
anything for my
second-favorite co-star."
And I was like,
"What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
Who's your first?"
And he was like, "Me."
I mean, I can't fight with that.
-You can't fight with that.
-Yeah, I can't fight with that.
-You got to be second to that.
He's a good guy.
You were saying
in some interview I read
that you read the script
for "The Marvels" and you go,
"This is unbelievable."
-Oh, yeah, it's bonkers.
-"I don't know how you
can pull this off."
-Yeah. I mean,
it's been, like, a while now
where I've been like,
"I can't believe I have
to hold the secret.
It's just -- It's absurd."
I mean, there's been things
every day when we were filming,
where I was like,
"If my friends only knew what
I was doing right now --"
I had to learn
all new skill sets.
There was a lot that -- Yeah,
we go to planets that are
pretty cool, yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
I think so. I think so.
-I think after the first
you came on the show
and we were talking,
and you were like --
I said, "How much time do you
spend in wires and floating?"
You go, "Ooh, a lot of time."
-Oh, well, yeah.
-So, you're hung --
I mean, to fly, you have
to be on wires and stuff.
-I mean, If you think about it,
like, if you could fly,
you probably would.
Like, if I was just, like --
If you're walking
from here to here,
you're not going to walk over.
You're going to levitate over.
If you can go 2 inches
off of the ground,
like, you're going to do it.
Which, like,
seems like a cool idea,
but just to anybody out there
who's, like, thinking
of becoming a superhero
or like you're a superhero,
and then, suddenly, you can fly,
like, just know it means
an eternal wedgie
for everything you
ever do after that.
Like, you just don't
think about it.
You're like, "Cool!
I can fly. Wow!"
And you do it one time,
you're like, "Peter Pan! Cool!"
And then you're like, "Oh, no!
Actually,
this is so uncomfortable.
And now I have to be cool
and, like,
talk about, like,
helping people,
but, like, really,,
I'm in a full-body plank,
and it's just, like --" It's a
lot of core strength, folks.
It's a lot. It's a lot.
And you're just kind of, like,
airlifted up and around
and you're just, like,
holding that, just being like,
"We really got to do this. Ugh!"
It's like -- So, you know,
it's acting is what I'm saying.
-Yeah, it's acting.
-It's acting.
-But I have a couple
behind-the-scenes clips
that you brought just
for us of you in rehearsal.
-Oh, I hope they're cool.
-Yeah.
Well, let's check
this first one out here.
Let's just...
Look at the --
You see the wires here.
There's the wires.
You walk out to the front yard.
"Hey, what's up guys?
How you doing?"
And whoa!
I mean, that's fun.
-That is fun.
That is fun.
-But that's amazing.
-Yeah.
-But then --
-That's my job, guys.
Like, that's my job.
-Yeah, that's your job.
-So that's wild.
-I want to show another one.
Here's a clip of you on these
wires of acting and fighting.
-Action!
-Okay.
-Look at this.
-Fly! Punch, punch!
Fly! Land, punch.
-I mean, come on!
That is a pro.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-That's a pro right there.
-Just like
a little burger order.
"Fly, punch, punch,
land, punch."
-"Fly, land, punch."
-Yeah, of course.
-What do we say about
"The Marvels"?, except for --
-What do we say?
-Yeah.
Well, I know
we're not really allowed to say.
-I don't think we're allowed
to say anything.
-You really aren't.
-Go see it, please.
And then we can talk about it,
because until then, I cannot.
I've been so excited
to talk about this movie.
I just love my cast
so much in this.
Nia DaCosta,
our director, is incredible.
-Yes! Talk about it.
-Yes. Oh, she's just amazing.
She's amazing.
And I think you're going to get
to see just incredible planets
and teamwork and just humor
and love and friendship.
And I'm just really
excited about it.
So I hope you go see it.
-I love having actors
on the show
talking about their projects.
I'm so excited.
I want to show a clip.
Here's our pal Brie Larson
in "The Marvels."
Take a look.
-Annihilator.
-I don't like that name.
♪♪
-♪ Ratata ♪
♪ Go ratata, ratata ♪
♪ DJ Skrillex,
we be the realest team ♪
♪ I'm the illest,
watch how I kill it ♪
♪ Watch how I spit it
on the mic, feel it ♪
♪ Y'all can't do what I do,
just admit it ♪
♪ I'm 'bout to get it,
money, money, get it ♪
♪ Drop it to the floor,
my face look pretty ♪
♪ Y'all ain't doin'...new,
I done did it ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm marvelous,
fantabulous ♪
♪ A bad chick, the flow's sick,
like oh, oh, ♪
♪ You know this,
I'm too fit to ever quit ♪
♪ Knockin' these fools out
like pool sticks ♪
-Friends of yours?
-Hi.
-♪ Like a pound of bricks ♪
♪ It go up jump the boogie
to the bang-bang, ha ♪
♪ This the kind of beat
that to ratata ♪
-Ooh! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Brie Larson, everyone.
"The Marvels"
is in theaters now.
Brie and I are doing
something fun after the break.
Stick around. Come on back.